auf der suche nach der strategie das
saarland will corona beschränkungen nach
ostern lockern
das rkw plädiert für einen strengen
shutdown verdacht und vertrauen der eu
gipfel berät über exportbeschränkungen
für impfstoffe corona fall im
nationalteam jonas hofmann wurde positiv
getestet das wm-quali-spiel gegen island
findet trotzdem statt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievert in allen die welt an
diesem donnerstag schön dass sie mit
dabei sind sport nachher in der sendung
mit katja stresow und nannte
deutschlands politik sucht nach einem
plan gegen das virus und für eine
vorsichtige rückkehr in ein normales
leben idealerweise sollte beides
zugleich funktionieren
es zeigt sich aber die gegensätze sind
groß zumal sich alles vor diesem
hintergrund abspielt wenn wir uns jetzt
mal genauer ansehen können
zum ersten mal seit zwei monaten hat die
zahl der korona neuinfektionen wieder
die marke 20.000 überschritten
dem robert koch institut wurden aktuell
22 1657 neuinfektionen gemeldet 5153
mehr als vergangenen donnerstag
das sind die nackten zahlen wie es
weitergehen sollen dazu gibt es
unterschiedliche vorstellungen der chef
des robert koch instituts sieht keine
andere lösung als einen strengen
shutdown
der ministerpräsident des saarlands will
mit seinem bundesland nach ostern
schrittweise aus dem shutdown aussteigen
abgesichert durch massenhafte
schnelltests auf die setzen auch viele
andere bundesländer
isabel de la vega ein kulturzentrum in
wiesbaden hier kann man sich seit zwei
wochen kostenlos schnell testen lassen
doch viele scheinen das noch nicht zu
wissen roger moore ist überrascht wie
einfach es war einen termin zu bekommen
gezeiten link im internet wo man drauf
geht und dann kann man auch super
kurzfristig sind noch tickets frei und
habe für eine freundin die gleichkommt
gebucht vor 3 stunden für jetzt glaube
ich die infrastruktur fürs schnell
testen steht anbieter sind
drogeriemärkte wie hier in mainz
hausarztpraxen oder apotheken
deutschlandweit gibt es große
unterschiede bei der anzahl der test
stellen so verfügt berlin über 130 nrw
über mehr als 4700 corona schnell test
stellen im saarland sind die tests teil
eines neuen modellversuchs mit
lockerungen nach ostern soll es möglich
sein mit einem tagesaktuellen negativen
testergebnis ins restaurant
der kino zu gehen ich finde es
grundsätzlich gut dass wir mutig sind
halt sagen wir versuchen das mit den
tests und ja wenn es so angeboten wird
hier und alles klappt bin ich
zuversichtlich dass wir dann ein
bisschen mehr freiheit genießen können
mehr freiheit das verspricht auch die
politik erstens das infektionsgeschehen
ist im saarland derzeit moderat zweitens
wir verfügen
im ländervergleich über eine der besten
test infrastruktur schnell testen und
lockern das will die eine seite andere
folgen den virologen und bezeichnen
lockerungen bei steigenden instanzen als
fahrlässig bei diesem modell projekten
geht es um zusätzliche lockerungen also
wie kann ich lockerungen sicherer machen
und genau das brauchen wir jetzt nicht
gebrauchen ja keine lockerungen sondern
wir brauchen eine verschärfung mehr
sicherheit oder mehr freiheit auch bei
den schnelltests scheiden sich die
geister testen und impfen bei beidem
sieht die bundeskanzlerin noch
verbesserungsbedarf heute im parlament
und in dem punkt stimmt ihr die
opposition zu
welche strategie dieses land jetzt
einschlagen soll ob es überhaupt eine
echte strategie gibt oder nicht doch
viel zu viel verwirrung darum drehte
sich die debatte thomas reichert fasst
zusammen am tag nach ihrer
entschuldigung hat angela merkel ist
eigentlich ans rednerpult zu kommen zu
eilig es soll jetzt nicht mehr nur um
ihre fehler gehen sondern auch um die
verantwortung der länder und kommunen
und die frage wie zu packen sie sind im
kampf gegen die gefährlichen virus
mutationen
wir sind ein föderaler staat es ist
keinem oberbürgermeister und keinem
landrat verwehrt das zu tun was in
tübingen und rostock getan wird
alle können das macht und der bund wird
immer unterstützten tätigkeit
merkel kündigt schnelleres flexiblere
simpson an nach ostern auch in den rund
50.000 hausarztpraxen die afg fordert
dagegen dass deutschland aus der
europäischen impfstoff verteilung
ausschert er liegt im deutschen
interesse dass zuerst die bürger dieses
landes geimpft werden
darum hat sich die bundesregierung zu
kümmern merkel hofft mit breiten tests
die dritte virus welle zu kontrollieren
etwa in unternehmen verpflichtend aber
werden die erst wenn zu wenige firmen
freiwillig mitmachen wenn es stimmt dass
die pandemie dass das
infektionsgeschehen auch gerade in den
unternehmen so stark weiter gegeben wird
hätte man dies jetzt auch verbindlich
tun können die grünen fordern dass
endlich mehr tests in schulen und kitas
kommen wir brauchen 100 millionen wenn
wir alle kinder in diesem land zweimal
die woche testen wollen das ist nicht so
schwer auszurechnen
nachdem merkel sich mit strengeren
shutdown regeln nicht durchsetzen konnte
richtet sich nun also alle hoffnungen
darauf dass mehr getestet mehr geimpft
wird
was wo wie genau gelten soll es
unübersichtlich um es ganz vorsichtig zu
sagen
und natürlich besteht die große gefahr
dass die leute sagen ich blicke nicht
mehr durch ich fahre irgendwie meine
private linie
theo koll in berlin guten abend sind wir
jetzt ganz offiziell in der jedes land
jede kommune alle machen was sie wollen
phase naja wir scheinen zumindest
aktuell unterwegs sind eine labor
landschaft der länder
nordrhein-westfalen plant weiter keinen
regelunterricht nach den osterferien in
bremen machen sie ab kommender woche
museen und einkaufen auf termin wieder
dicht in sachsen-anhalt dagegen wird
zusätzlich geöffnet kultureinrichtungen
können dort unter bestimmten bedingungen
ja vor publikum wieder spielen und das
saarland wir haben es eben gehört will
nach ostern sogar grundsätzlich eröffnen
kinos fitnessstudios außengastronomie
wer im saarland ein stellte das
vorweisen kann für den gilt
gibt im land der lockerung was also bei
anderen natürlich sauer aufstößt das
saarland habe 80.000 zusätzliche
impfdosen bekommen weil es dort die
südafrikanische mutante gebe und nicht
um zu lockern
heißt es von frau schwesig seitdem
pannen gipfel vom montag scheint die
staatliche gemeinschaft steuerung weiter
an wert zu verlieren und die vorläufigen
daten eines politbarometer extra stellen
heute abend fest dass es bei den bürgern
einen massiven einbruch des vertrauens
gibt versucht dann am ende sich jeder
seinen eigenen weg
theo koll in berlin vielen dank diese
analyse heute abend alle die mit dem
flugzeug nach deutschland reisen müssen
künftig vor abflug einen negativen krohn
attest vorlegen
eine entsprechende einreise verordnung
soll morgen veröffentlicht werden und
dann ab sonntag gelten
von der regelung sind dann auch etwa
mallorca reisende über ostern betroffen
die insel war von der liste der
risikogebiete gestrichen worden weil sie
vergleichsweise niedrige
infektionszahlen hat eine neue
entwicklung in der masken affäre es geht
jetzt um den ehemaligen cdu
bundestagsabgeordneten mag hauptmann
bisher war der wegen zwielichtiger deals
mit aserbaidschan aufgefallen
der verdacht der staatsanwaltschaft
jetzt bestechlichkeit
er soll offenbar auch in lukrative
geschäfte mit schutzmasken verwickelt
sein und dafür fast eine million euro
kassiert haben
ermittler durchsuchten heute seine
wohnung und büros melanie haack
berichtet es geht um beweismittel das
lka durchsucht das ehemalige thüringer
wahlkreisbüro von marc hauptmann
geschäftsstellen der cdu thüringen und
hauptmanns büro im bundestag
es wird gegen ihn ermittelt wegen masken
geschäften und hohe provisionen
erst vor zwei wochen hatte mag hauptmann
sein bundestagsmandat niedergelegt
unter anderem soll er für die
vermittlung von corona schutzmasken in
seiner funktion als
bundestagsabgeordneter ab frühjahr 2020
provisionszahlungen von mehreren 100.000
euro erhalten haben
dem wird der verdacht der
bestechlichkeit vorgeworfen in seiner
funktion als bundestagsabgeordneter eben
als mandatsträger auch eine firma im
frankfurt wurde heute durchsucht sie
soll dem politiker geld für die
vermittlung von geschäften mit corona
schutzmasken gezahlt haben
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft thüringen
hat 997 1000 euro seines vermögens
eingefroren
über eine von ihm gegründete firma soll
hauptmann für die masken vermittlung die
provision in rechnung gestellt haben
lobbycontrol fordert veränderungen wir
müssen hier einfach wirklich einen
großen wurf machen bei den regeln für
abgeordnete um solche fälle künftig zu
verhindern
mag hauptmann hatte bislang
unrechtmäßige masken geschäfte
bestritten
die cdu thüringen distanziert sich von
ihm das für uns eine tiefe enttäuschung
und von daher hat auch unser
landesvorsitzender christian würde heute
herrn hauptmann aufgefordert seine
parteimitgliedschaft unmittelbar wieder
zulegen die staatsanwaltschaft will
jetzt die beschlagnahmten unterlagen
auswerten
wann kommt endlich genug impfstoff die
drängende frage stellt sich auch beim
virtuellen eu gipfel heute auf dem tisch
liegt der vorschlag weit reichende
exportbeschränkungen für impfstoff das
könnte vor allem den konzern astrazeneca
treffen der bislang deutlich weniger an
die eu geliefert hat als eigentlich
zugesagt bis ende märz sollte der
hersteller laut eu-kommission 120
millionen dosen liefern
nun werden es maximal 30 millionen
und während möglichst viele menschen
weiter in das vertrauen in das produkt
von astrazeneca haben sollen ist das
vertrauen der eu in die ehrlichkeit des
managements größtenteils dahin stefan
leifert in brüssel welche gewaltigen
vorwürfe stehen im raum
der verdacht der ja schon seit wochen im
raum steht ist der dass astrazeneca
trotz massiver lieferrückstände
gegenüber der eu großbritannien
notorisch bevorzugt und dieser verdacht
wurde heute nochmal durch neue zahlen
verschärft die eu kommission heute beim
gipfel vorgestellt hat demnach wurden
seit anfang dezember 20 millionen
impfdosen in der eu hergestellt aber
dann nach großbritannien exportiert und
davon natürlich auch viele von
astrazeneca dass sich daran durch diesen
verschärften export mechanismus mit dem
sich der gipfel heute besteht
sich grundsätzlich etwas ändert ist eher
unwahrscheinlich dieser mechanismus wird
mehr transparenz bringen
jede impfdosen die die eu verlässt muss
künftig in brüssel angezeigt werden aber
das wirklich exporte gestoppt werden ist
eher unwahrscheinlich das zeigen die
zahlen der vergangenheit von über 300
anträgen auf export hat die eu
kommission fast alle genehmigt nur einen
einzigen gestoppt und bei dieser tendenz
dürfte es auch künftig wohl bleiben
stefan läufer zdf busse dankeschön so
viel zunächst in dieser sendung zum
thema corona jetzt weitere wichtige
nachrichten von heute
der bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan
soll um zehn monate verlängert werden
darüber berät der bundestag in diesen
minuten in den vergangenen 20 jahren
waren dort zeitweise mehr als 5000
deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten
stationiert seit dem ende des
kampfeinsatzes 2014 sind es deutlich
weniger
die meisten von ihnen beraten heute und
bilden aus und zwar afghanische
sicherheitskräfte in masar i scharif
katrin eigendorf die angst vor
terroranschlägen ist alltäglich geworden
auch in masar i scharif gibt es
kontrollpunkte an allen hauptstraßen
camp marmal das größte ausländische
feldlager der bundeswehr
ein hochsicherheitstrakt 1100 soldaten
und soldatinnen sind hier derzeit im
einsatz
seit 2015 hat deutschland im norden die
federführung für die nato-mission
resolut support die jetzt fortgeführt
wird
im kern geht es nach afghanischen
streitkräfte zu unterstützen
effektiver effizienter und vor allem
auch durch alle fliegen
die sicherheitslage hier umfassend
reagieren zu können
mubarak war ein kind als vor 20 jahren
die ersten deutschen kamen obwohl der
ladenbesitzer ihren einsatz
grundsätzlich positiv sieht setzt er
seine hoffnung nicht mehr auf die
bundeswehr
unser größtes problem ist dass wir
frieden brauchen wenn es frieden gibt
dann ist es egal ob die truppen bleiben
oder abziehen
in den dörfern des nordens ist wenig
spürbar von dem fortschritt den die usa
und ihre verbündeten erreichen wollten
noch immer zählt afghanistan zu den
ärmsten und gefährlichsten ländern der
welt
unser afghanistan wurde an ausländische
staaten verkauft und so viel wir auch
versucht haben es wird keinen frieden
geben dass die internationalen truppen
jetzt nicht abziehen
darauf hatten vor allem die regierung
und menschenrechtsgruppen gedrängt die
taliban dagegen drohen mit krieg darauf
wird die bundeswehr sich einstellen
müssen
die deutsche industrie befürchtet
lieferengpässe weil der suezkanal immer
noch blockiert ist eine der wichtigsten
handelsrouten zwischen asien und europa
noch immer liegt dort ein riesiger
containerfrachter quer schlepper
versuchten auch heute ihn wieder in die
spur zu manövrieren
mittlerweile stellen sich mehr als 100
andere schiffe der frachter war am
dienstag wegen eines sandsturms auf
grund gelaufen
zurück nach deutschland zuletzt hatten
ermittler ganze netzwerke aufgedeckt
dutzende kinder sind opfer von sexuellem
missbrauch geworden
jetzt hat der bundestag das gesetz
verschärft sexuelle gewalt gegen kinder
wird künftig grundsätzlich als
verbrechen eingestuft und kann somit
mindestens einem jahr haft bestraft
werden
das gilt auch für den besitz und die
verbreitung von bildern oder filme
schauen wir vor einem prozess in
wiesbaden der licht in den größten
deutschen finanzskandal bringen soll
es geht um sogenannte comex geschäfte
über jahre ließen sich investoren
kapitalertragssteuern mehrfach erstatten
so entstand ein milliardenschaden für
die staatskasse am ersten
verhandlungstag in wiesbaden fehlte
allerdings eine der schlüsselpersonen
günther neufeld berichtet wegen corona
verhandelt das gericht in einer extra
aufgebauten halle auf der grünen wiese
sechs männer wollte man eigentlich in
wiesbaden vor gericht stellen weil sie
den deutschen staat betrogen haben
sollen um 113 millionen euro erschienen
sind nur zwei von ihnen die anderen
halten sich im ausland auf darunter eine
zentrale figur rechtsanwalt hanno berger
der ehemalige finanzbeamte wechselte die
seiten und erklärte schwerreichen
anlegern wie sieht noch reicher werden
konnten durch sogenannte comex deals mit
riesigen aktienpaketen rund um den
termin der dividendenzahlung die papiere
schopmann so trickreich hin und her dass
das finanzamt nicht mehr folgen konnte
am ende wurden steuern zweimal zurück
erstattet die nur einmal gezahlt worden
waren
es handle sich bei comics geschäften und
den größten steuer raub in der
geschichte deutschlands es geht um ein
steuerschaden von über 30 milliarden
euro
wir haben über 1000 beschuldigte und es
wird in 70 fällen ermittelt vor gericht
stehen jetzt zwei ehemalige mitarbeiter
der hypo vereinsbank die keinen wohnsitz
im ausland haben
der mutmaßliche drahtzieher der
geschäfte hat sich erst einmal in
sicherheit gebracht anwalt berger lebt
im schweizer bergdorf zu es und beteuert
seine unschuld
ob die schweiz hinaus liefert ist
fraglich so kann er nun vom sonnigen
engadin aus verfolgen die anderen
beschuldigten der prozess gemacht wird
die theologin uta ranke heinemann war
laut und streitbar und sie schonte ihre
kirche nicht heute ist sie gestorben
sie war weltweit die erste professorin
für katholische theologie
doch die kirche entzog er später die
lehrbefugnis weil sie nicht an die
jungfrauengeburt jesu glauben wollte
und auch das sind zitate von ihr mit
denen sie die kirchenoberen provozierte
das kirchenrecht sei eine sammlung
maskuliner irakischer arroganz der
vatikan ein frauen loses terrarium
sie engagierte sich auch in der
friedensbewegung und trat 1999 erfolgt
für die pds bei der
bundespräsidentenwahl ein guter ranke
heinemann wurde 93 jahre alt und jetzt
in der seine beim sport angekommen bei
katja ja und es gibt große unruhe vor
dem wm qualifikationsspiel der fußball
nationalelf gegen island
mittelfeldspieler jonas hofmann wurde
positiv auf corinna getestet und muss
genau wie seine kontaktperson marcel
halstenberg in quarantäne
nils kaben vor dem stadion in duisburg
warum kann das spiel trotzdem
stattfinden
ganz einfach gesagt weil noch genug
spieler da sind die nicht in quarantäne
geschickt worden sind der dfb konnte
gegenüber dem gesundheitsamt düsseldorf
glaubhaft versichern dass nur marcel
halstenberg so engen kontakt zum positiv
getesteten jonas hofmann hatte das als
kontaktperson der kategorie eins gilt
darüber hinaus ist das hygiene konzept
hier bei der nationalmannschaft sehr
ausgeklügelt die mannschaft ist gerade
in zwei bussen hier im stadion
angekommen damit jeder seine eigene
reihe hat es wird in schichten gegessen
überall herrscht masken pflicht damit
eben im falle eines falles sowie in
heute erlebt haben nicht gleich die
ganze mannschaft dran ist darüber hinaus
wurden alle heute mittag noch mal
schnell getestet negativ natürlich aber
ein restrisiko bleibt natürlich aufgrund
der inkubationszeit des mehr sind ein
paar tagen ob es da noch den ein oder
anderen spieler mehr erwischt haben
könnte danke für die information
schlimme auftakt beim skiflug weltcup in
planica slowenien der norweger daniel
andrä tante verloren probedurchgang nach
dem absprung die kontrolle über seine
ski prallte auf den hang und blieb
regungslos im auslauf liegen wo er
wiederbelebt werden musste er wurde ins
krankenhaus geflogen
seine verletzungen seien nicht
lebensbedrohlich hieß es eben mit einem
jahr verspätung hat in japan der
olympische fackellauf begonnen die
flamme die das licht am ende des tunnels
symbolisieren soll wird 121 tage
unterwegs sein und startete an einem
ganz besonderen ort reise beginnt der
fackellauf in fukushima zehn jahre nach
der atomkatastrophe will japan ein
zeichen der hoffnung aus senden
allerdings ohne zuschauer am start wegen
der pandemie das letzte jahr war
schwierig für die gesamte welt aber wir
haben das olympisch
nie erlöschen lassen gerade erst hat die
regierung den ausnahmezustand in der
stadt aufgehoben
sie fordert die bürger aber auf massen
weiter zu meiden
olympische spiele in zeiten von corona
sieht die mehrheit der japaner eher
kritisch ich finde man sollte nicht
krampfhaft an den spielen festhalten
olympische spiele mit einem jahr
verspätung japan will der welt ein
lächeln schicken
trotz pandemie am 23 juli soll es in
tokio losgehen vielen dank hat ja so ich
habe jetzt noch diese aussichten für sie
mildes frühlingswetter morgen und dann
wieder ungemütlich samstag
mehr dazu gleich von osten tätig wir
alle hier bei den 19 uhr nachrichten
duncan hat sich für ihr interesse die
kollegin marietta slomka hat das heute
journal um 21.45 ich sag bis morgen und
wünsche ihnen allen ein angenehmer abend
[Musik]
ein schulamt und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter und erreicht weiteren warme luft
aus dem südwesten europas allerdings
wird diese wärme vorübergeht dann
gestört und zwar erreicht uns dann am
samstag kalte luft aus dem nordwesten
die bewölkung die zieht schon morgen ab
den nachmittagsstunden und vor allem am
abend auf und in der nacht gibt es dann
regen in der kommenden nacht gibt es nur
einige schauer und zwar mit diesem
wolkenband hier quer über deutschland
ansonsten ist es meist aufgelockert und
die temperaturen sinken an den alpen bis
auf minus zwei grad im nordwesten sind
es sechs grad oder auch richtung elbe
ähnlichkeit mit 6 grad
morgen dann viel sonne scheint vor allem
richtung alpen und auch im süden häufig
sonnige abschnitte ganz im westen kommt
die bewölkung auf und richtung nordsee
da tröpfelt es auch etwas und das bei
temperaturen von bis zu 18 grad im
südwesten deutschlands und 12 grad in
schleswig-holstein häufig werte über der
15 grad marke der blick auf die
kommenden tage am samstag wird es sehr
wechselhaft von westen her mit der
kaltluft schauer gewitter
graupel gewitter sind dabei sechs bis
zwölf grad und ab sonntag wird es wärmer
und vor allem montag bis 21 grad
ein schöner abend